It
was a response that I didn't
think I wouldn't
say ana from before.
I'm Yuzaki, please don't rotate with the starry sky
.
Ha
Chitchi, let's take a look at the keys Chitose Chitose Mountain Car That's a
nice name, no, no, you said it's a net value, so I guess I'm about 14
Well, it's noon, so we'll have lunch nearby
.
It was a sudden conversation, and we
're both still young, but maybe that's why it's good to change
places and have a long
talk.I think what we lack is communication.
Chitose doesn't sound like something you'll be convinced by, but it's okay Even so,
you'll be convinced, and we'll become a couple I hope we have
communication Today,
if you die,
pane
[music]
goonie
The place you want  The rice that changed the